Okay, so what, uh, what
problem are we trying to solve?
You're trying to solve
the problem of masses,
couple of the springs and uh,
acted upon by
various forces on the
equation that we need
is the following.
So this is the most general
problem.
We looked at this as f sub zero. I
may have this, call it f last name.
Doesn't matter. It's a
matter of this symbols. Okay.
All right.
Let us first divide everything by him.
You write everything by m,
then it becomes x double.plus Gamma X.
Dot.
Let's Omega zero squared.
X Equals F zero over M Cosine Omega T.
I'm using the fact that the Omega not
was defined as the root of k over that.
We used to call it Omega,
but now I'm calling it Omega not,
and you should understand why I'm doing
that because there are now two Omegas in
the problem that is the Omega of the
driving force. So you should imagine,
and also the 34th grabbing this
mass and moving it back and forth.
We'll make an art. It's the
natural frequency of the
math. If you pull the spring,
let it go.
That's the frequency which it will
vibrate that I really natural frequency.
But this fixed by K and M and
o may guys for you to decide,
you can decide to apply to it.
Any force you like have any frequency.
So first take the easy case in
which the right hand side is zero,
no driving force.
So I'm saying let's consider a simple
case f zero or f f the applied force
vanishes.
That's the problem I spent considerable
amount of time on yesterday.
You can say, well, if there's no
driving force, why does anything move?
That's actually correct. If
you look a mass in the spring
and it didn't, anything,
didn't do anything to it,
the solution to this equation,
this x equal to zero and that just fine,
but it also has interesting nontrivial
solutions because you can pull the mass
and then let it go after to let it go.
That are no forces on the system except
the force of friction and the force of
the spring and that has this problem.
How do you solve this problem?
I told you, the way you solve
this problem is you make a guess.
X of t is some number a times either the
Alpha t see if it'll work and you find
a little work and you
can this in your head.
I certainly don't want
to repeat all of that.
The reason it's going to work is that
every time you take a of to Webex,
you bring down an Alpha and
still keep eating the Alpha t.
So when he put that
gets into this equation,
you're going to get
alpha square plus gamma,
Alpha Omega Not Square famous,
a either the Alpha t equal to zero
and if this is going to vanish,
it's not big as the bay and it's not
because if you're the Alpha t is bigger,
this guy in brackets is going to vanish.
So that's zero. You all recognize
this to be a quadratic equation.
You go back to your days in the sandbox
when you all knew what the answer to
this is.
The answer to this is minus gamma over
to less than a minus GAM over to square
minus Omega, Not Square.
These are the roots.
Now here you have to look at. So
any of it, what does this mean?
This means that yes,
you can find a solution to this equation
that looks like a the Alpha tea.
It can be any number you like,
no restrictions placed on a,
but Alpha cannot be any number you like.
Alpha has to be the solution
to this quadratic equation.
And there are two solutions, so you can
call them Alpha plus an Alpha minus.
That's been, I branched off into
two different cases. Case one.
You can see, look, when you do the
quadratic equation, do you know the,
the way it's going to fall out is
depending on whether the stuff inside the
bracket is positive or negative.
So let's take the easier case.
When it's positive, that means gamble.
We're two is bigger than Omega,
not gamma. You remember
this, the force of friction.
So we wanted to be not only not zero,
but bigger than this amount controlled
by the natural frequency. In that case,
let's not go into details,
but you can all see, uh,
you put whatever value you have for gamma.
The square root of this is some number.
The whole thing is going to
be two real choices you get.
One will be minus gamma over two plus
whatever it is inside the square root,
other we minus gamma over two
minus what you have in this way.
The only thing I want you to notice is
that both these routes are negative.
This guy's obviously negative because
there's a minus GAM or two minus something
else.
That's definitely a negative.
You may be a little worried here that
this is mine as GAM while we're doing this
plus something,
but the plus something is smaller than
the minus something because what's inside
the square root is gamma over to square.
If it did this quadrant of that,
you will get exactly gam over to what
you're taking away from it. This number,
therefore, this square root is
bigger, smarter than this number.
So the overall thing
will still on negative.
So why am I so eager that
it should come off negative?
Why am eager to the
rules should be negative?
Yes.
Uh, no. Even if I had
positive [inaudible] workout.
Yes,
out
greater than one.
Then
one converse to what?
This is not a course sign function.
This is never going to be a cost sine
functions related to either the eye omega
t or eat the [inaudible]. These
are all real exponential. Yes,
yes.
Yeah. That's some of the main problem
when you write an exponential function,
usually people write exponential.
It's like this for population growth.
Everyone says our problem is
that increasing exponentially.
They always think of exponential
as rising. Of course,
it's also possible that if alphabet and
negative number, you could write it as a
play mc absolute value of Alpha just to
show you it's a falling explanations and
we have a stomach only for falling
exponentials. You got to think,
if I pull this mass and then let it go,
I expect x to go down from whatever value
I had not to keep growing indefinitely.
That doesn't make any physical sense and
one of the great things about the Union
of mathematics and physics is the
equation automatically works out that way.
It gives you an answer.
That makes sense. Okay.
So what you get then is a solution that
looks like this one number eight times
either the one of the routes,
uh,
plus another number B times either.
The other route I wrote them,
they are both here,
the Alpha t but I write it
is minus the absolute value.
So you can all see that
falling exponentials.
You understand if a number is negative,
like negative five,
that can be written as the minus one
times the absolute value of the number.
So it is either the Alpha t but I want
to write it in this form so it's falling.
So this is a case where if you
pull the mass and you let it go,
it will just relax eventually
coming to x equals zero,
which is his normal location,
equilibrium location.
Now how about the numbers a and B?
Right now they are completely arbitrary.
And another thing you guys should
know by now is how we find a and B.
In order to find a and B,
we need to be given more information
other than simply the mass in the spring.
Constant, they are all sitting
here and the friction coefficient,
but that's not enough to tell you what
it does on a given day. It wants to know,
well,
yes it's the masters that spring,
but did you pull it or they do
release it in this way or that way.
That's what the control, the answer
their call, the initial conditions,
one initial condition is what the
value of x at time t equals zero.
That's asking you how much
you put it when you let it go.
The other initial condition
is what does the velocity,
namely the but the Webex at times you
most of the time what you will find as
you pull the mass in the release it then
it's got a non zero x
that a zero velocity,
but it doesn't have to be that way
because I could have pulled it and release
the teak.
Will the zero starting to move in words
and that's when you would jump in and
you set your clocks to zero but at that
instant excess of value and the velocity
also has a nonsuit about,
they don't all have to be zero but there
are some two numbers you can pick at
will.
You can see that if I put t equals zero
I'm going to get a zero which is one I'm
going to get a plus. B is x zero.
That's one condition on a and B.
Now we'll take a deliberative,
namely find the velocity,
then put t equal to zero and set that
equal to some pre assigned number.
You've got a second equation for amb
and we all know we can solve those two
equations to find a and B.
That's how you fit these three parameters
to the solution tailored made for that
particular situation.
You should also ask another question.
Why is it that I can pick
these numbers x not and be not,
but why not keep going? Maybe the
acceleration at time zero is some number.
Why is that not up to me to decide?
Can anyone tell me why
that's not negotiable?
Yes.
Okay.
Depends upon what can I pick the
acceleration of a body at will?
Yes.
That tells you,
yeah, I, I'm not sure they heard the
exact answer, but it sounds close.
Close enough to what I had in mind,
which is Newton will tell you what
the acceleration of our bodies,
namely mass times acceleration
is the force and the force.
Once it's given in any given problem,
which is given by where the body is and
what the velocity is. In this example,
you have no choice in
what the accelerations,
but initial position and velocity
are not given by Newton's law.
Newton's law says if the forest is so
and so, the acceleration is so and so,
but he doesn't tell you what should
be the velocity at a given time.
What would be the position at a
given time? That's why they are two,
three numbers.
That's why you have the answer with two,
three numbers that you can pick to bring
it in a card with these two numbers.
Okay. This solution to the
equation with x equals zero.
From now on,
I'm going to call x sub C,
but c stands for the
complimentary function.
Okay?
Now that is another thing that
could've happened here. Uh,
which is in fact another alternative. Let
me, you can think about what I'm saying.
The other alternative is when this gamma
over two is smarter than this Omega not.
Then of course you have the
square root of a negative number.
So then you go back to the stage where
they're finding the root and they say
alpha equals minus gamma or were two plus
and minus square root of GAM over two
squared minus omega, not square,
but that number is negative.
So that can be written as a negative
sign times the square root of this number
and the square root of minus one
will come over to us an I in front.
So either you will get to real roots.
This is a mathematical result.
Nothing to do with physics, a quadratic
equation with real coefficients.
Either we'll have two real roots or it
will have two routes which are complex
conjugates of each other. You'll learn
the notion of complex conjugation,
which is the item in the PSI.
You can see the Alpha plus Alpha minus
have the same reel part minus gamma or to
an opposite imaginary parts,
so in this example,
Alpha plus, it's the complex conjugate
of Alpha minus and I've totally,
this relationship works both ways.
Therefore,
Alpha minus is a complex con
to get them out for plus.
Yeah,
so what's the solution going to look like?
It's going to look like a e to the
minus gamma t over to either the eye
or make up prime t, but I'm going to call
this fellow in brackets as Omega prime.
Yeah.
Then there's the second solution.
The real part is exactly the same.
Imaginary part is opposite
minus I omega prime t
we'll make a prime is a new frequency
connected to the natural frequency and the
frictional force.
That's where we got three Omegas.
You've got to keep that in mind.
We'll make a nod is a natural frequency
vibration. If I have a driving force,
I reserved the symbol Omega for
the frequency of the driving force.
Here is yet another quantity
with units of frequency,
which I'm calling Omega Prime.
So what does this guy look like?
The first of all is full of complex
numbers and we don't like it.
We know the oscillator should have
a real coordinate. So you ask,
I have not picked a and B yet.
How shall I pick them? So x's real
well, forget a and B for a minute and
look at this number and this number.
Do you guys realize that they're
complex conjugates of each other?
Because I had gone to minus sign.
So for example,
if a and be able to equal numbers,
this would be a real number because
a number of pluses conjugate,
you kill the imaginary part because
they have opposite imaginative parts.
So A and B reel is a good answer,
but it's too restrictive.
All we will demand instead of a looks
like absolutely family of times either the
IFI B should look like absolute value
of a plan, either the minus sized pie,
in other words be should be
the complex gone to get an a.
That means the same absolute value,
but opposite phase.
I didn't mind doing the complex plane.
If a numberZ is sitting there,
the complex spine together, sitting
here, they have opposite angles. Fine.
Yeah,
so if you do that,
then you get a absolute value either to
the miners gam over two times e to the I
Omega prime t plus five
plus e to the minus.
I may get prime t plus Fi.
Now we have made it real.
Yeah, and be bought.
Being fully real means this five year
zero but you see fight doesn't really have
to be zero.
That is too much of a distraction.
Fight can be whatever you like
provided the fight that he has,
the phase that it has same
as the phase that B has.
That means the angle in the complex plane
of the number eight the number be have
to be opposite of each other.
This,
you guys should know what it is. I've
told you many times this is unforgivable.
If you don't know what this is,
you're the ITA replicated the minus
I data over to his core science data.
Since you don't have the over to,
you can read it as to a
either minus GAM over to call
sign of whatever is in here,
Omega prime t plus Fi.
At this point I'm going to change and
rotation a little bit in view of what's to
come. Instead of calling this
Fi, I'm going to call it fi zero,
right? Because another fire is going to
come in and I want to separate those two.
So two times a is a new number.
I'm going to call that C and this is
the bottom line answer looks like either
minus gamma t over two host sine
Omega prime t plus five zero s
so we had, we had done all this
yesterday. I've given you the notes,
but I want you to understand
where we are going with all of this.
If you pull a mass and let it go,
it turns out that are two
things that can happen.
I really wish I had time to bring you
these different masses and show you.
If you have no friction,
everyone knows what's going to happen.
You pull the out and let it go. It
oscillates forever. In real life,
there is always some friction,
so let's turn a little friction.
What'll happen is what's very familiar,
unexpected.
It started with an aptitude of five.
Go to Ford to go to three, go to rock,
back and forth and slowly. It may be
around, but you won't be able to see it.
That's called a damped oscillation.
That's really what's described
by this solution here.
It looks like a course sign of something,
but the number in front of it itself is
falling with time and the picture for
that look like the following.
If you just draw an
exponentially falling function,
that's your amplitude and you multiply
that by an oscillating course, sign it.
We'll do this. This is
it. Damped Oscillation,
but another extreme case,
which you may not think about this,
if you crank up the friction more, they'll
gamma over two is bigger than Omega,
not. Then what happens is if
you pull the mass and let it go,
it doesn't even go to the
other side of x equal to zero.
It just slowly gets you to zero
in infinite amount of time.
You understand that if you pull
it from here, you let it go.
No friction is this for eternity.
Smaller monitor friction is slowly damped,
oscillation,
too much of friction.
You come back slowly and you come to rest.
These are,
there are different cases and the
mathematics tells you the different cases.
So that's what we like about the
Union of mathematics and physics.
Once you wrote down the
Basic Law of Newton,
you have no choice as to where
it takes you go where it takes.
These are the different types of
options. Okay, so this was uh,
what I did earlier on in the day,
but now let's go back to the more
general problem I had with this uh,
right hand side,
which is not zero.
So let's write the right hand side
is an not zero x double.plus Gamma X.
Dot. Omega notch squared, x equalsF ,
naught over and m costs Omega t.
This is called the driven oscillator
oscillators, the present all the time.
For example, if you have a swing
swing goes back and forth, you may,
you may choose to push the swing back
and forth. If you've got a kid in a park,
you're applying a force,
which is an oscillating force.
Whereas in the absence of external forces,
all oscillations will eventually die down.
You guys understand that?
Why? Why do all our solutions die down
in the absence of external forces?
Yes. Yeah. Well, in this case,
it's not addresses but friction.
But what friction does is that
in the presence of friction,
you cannot prove a law of
conservation of energy.
We saw that whenever friction acts, the
energy total mechanical energy goes down.
So candidate plus potential
will decrease with time.
So the installations get down.
But if you are pushing it from outside,
you can provide a constant source of
energy so we can maintain a steady
oscillation. And that's the problem
we're looking at. That is this problem.
So how did we solve this problem?
But I said,
I don't want to solve this equation. I'm
going to manufacture it. Another problem.
Z double.plus Gamma Times Z.
Dot.
Let's Omega Not Square.
Z is f naught over em.
Eat with the Iomega.
So let's be very clear. This is the real
physics problem that occurs the time.
This is clearly not of
Auburn world because in our
world you don't have a force
either. The iomega t all forces
in the real world or real,
so this is a complex force. If
you break down the Edi, Omega,
t you all know it's cost to make a tea,
which I like.
Lists I assign Omega t with.
They don't like.
I'm solving a problem in which on
top of the force I'm really applying.
That's the imaginary
force put on top of it.
So what does the strategy where we've
taken the problem and making it worse than
it is? Because we have a strategy.
The strategy is the following.
If you have a right hand side costs,
I may get d,
Ask yourself what you're trying to do.
You're looking for some function.
X of t we should obey this equation.
You can try various function,
maybe excess of cost, sign of time.
If it's of course not enough time to
deliver. This will be a coastline,
no date of it. It will be
assigned. One did have a doable,
I'm gonna study nor delivered.
It will be a course in one day it will
be assigned so you cannot make it into
your cost side. If it took a sign, the
middle guy will look like of course sign.
You can try to balance that against this.
The end two terms look like coastline.
So neither a sign,
not a coastline works I turned,
so something in between we'll work,
but something that always
works is the following.
If the right hand side
instead of being constant,
mega t was either the Iomega t you
can guess the answer immediately,
namely z itself will behave like the
Iomega tea because then if I take two
diverters, that's going to look
like either the Iomega tee time.
Some numbers that's going to look like a
[inaudible] mega t that's going to look
like Edi,
Omega t.
So the beauty of the exponential that
when you take directives you keep getting
the exponential
okay.
But now the problem is
this is not the problem.
No one told you to solve this problem,
but our strategy is the following.
The right hand side has got a
real force and imaginary force,
the real force and produce the ex
that I won the imaginary force,
purely imaginary items, send a mega t
will produce a purely imaginary answer.
So at the end of the day, I will find
the answer and keep only the real part.
That's the plan.
That's going to be the strategy.
So that this z a d,
this the is going to be the ex that I
want and we'll have a part hanging around.
Why that I don't want,
but why is being driven by the sine
Omega t and x is being driven by the
constant Manga te but now
let's solve it by inspection.
So let's make a guess that z
looks like some numbers. Z,
not even the Iomega t
no,
it's very easy to take delivered of
exponential gets pulled down Iomega every
time you see a date of it too.
So z double dot will become Iomega Square,
which is minus Omega squared.
Z.
Dot will become Iomega.
There's a gamma there and Omega and
square is multiplying by a number.
So this is what I get on the left hand
side and I wanted to equal this on the
right hand side.
And you're almost there because the time
dependence of the two sites that are
identical so you can cancel it.
And what you find is yes,
I can satisfy the equation that's
given to me throw wide the numberZ ,
not the numbers in front of
it, or B, is this condition.
Okay,
that's trivially solved because we
all know how to get the solution.
That one zene art is opened by dividing
both sides by everything that multiplies
the knot,
which happens to be well make gun r
squared minus Omega Square less Iomega
gamble.
So the
beautiful property,
the exponential function is that you
take what is a differential equation,
turn it into an Algebraic equation,
okay?
Because the act of taking derivatives
generally is a nasty operations.
Science become coastlines. Excused become
three x square, but exponential domains,
the exponential, that's the
property you'd find next blind here.
So now we got z not to be this one
and z itself.
The function.
The complex function looking for is f
not over m e to the I Omega t divided by
this quantity downstairs.
This quantity downstairs
I'm going to call Ifo Omega
I Omega is the complex number.
It's got a real part and an imaginary
part. The real part is on mega,
not square minus Omega squared.
Imaginary part is Omega Gamma.
It's not a fixed complex number like every
frequency of the driving force Omega,
it's the different complex number,
but if you're sitting at one
frequency of the driving force,
it is a particular number.
Everyone should know how to work it out.
We'll mega an artist root of k over them
or make has given to you that some real
number gamma's given to you.
That's an imaginary part.
If you actually put the numbers, it might
look like six plus five I in the end,
the the thing I call impedance
that I is just a complex number,
but it varies from frequency to frequency.
You can see that,
okay, now we got Zift. If the
problem given to us wasZ ,
we are done. You don't have to do
any motor work. Here's the answer,
but we were told to take the real part
of this answer because x was a real part
of the answer. Why he was not part of
the game. How do you take the deal part?
Your temptation may be well,
eat the Iomega t is costing me
got deeper as ice sine omega.
Teresa dropped the ice sine Omega
t but that would not be right.
Why is that not right?
Anyone know why that's not the
way to get the real part yet? Yep.
Yes.
Okay.
Yes. This number downstairs, it's not
a real number. It's a complex number,
so if you have a complex number on the
top divided by complex number in the
bottom, the deal part is not simply the
real part of the top. You've got right,
the whole thing,
so you can clearly separate the real
and imaginary parts and that's what I'm
going to do next.
Every complex number we know can be
written as an absolute value times either
the iPhone, right? Every
z looks like mark Z,
either the item data because
then it's Margie cost data,
which is x plus eight times more
designed data. Which is Iwai.
Every complex number
can be written that way.
And what would be the magnitude of this
guy? Well, by the Pythagoras Theorem,
it'd be the square of the rail part
less the square of the
imaginary part under roof.
Every complex number that you have,
we'll have an absolute value,
which is that squared with that square
on the route and it'll have a phase fi or
being the condition tan fi is the
imaginary part divided by the rail park.
Yeah.
I want you to realize that in a given
problem with a given mass given friction
given frequency board,
these are no,
there's simply a magnitude of I and the
phase Phi can be found by this process.
Now write it like that.
Then you get FCO over m
divided by absolute value of
I eat of the Ifi and I got
either to the Omega t on the top.
I'm almost there.
I'm almost there because either the IFI
in the bottom, can I put it in his ear?
The minus IFI on the top.
So did this whole thing becomes FCO over
m divided by the absolute value of I
eat the I Omega t minus five.
No, it's easier to take the deal part
because this is constant mega t minus five
plus I sine Omega t minus five.
These are all real numbers so they're
just multiplied the whole thing.
But the real to imagine that the
separation now comes from just taking the
course and part of this exponential
and that is our final answer.
That's the answer we've been looking for,
which is x of t is equal to f zero over
m divided absolute value of I of course
in Omega t minus Fi.
Why did we go through the whole
business a complex numbers.
We went there because the
answer is not a cost center.
It's not assigned and may get
the minus fi if you know your,
your trigonometry is costing me.
Got The by minus sine Omega t signed fine.
So you've gotten some costs.
Omega t has got some sine Omega t and
that's why it's hard to guess that answer.
But if you go to the complex numbers,
it comes off very easily.
Yeah.
So the next thing is to analyze the
properties of the answer you got.
You can write this whole thing in front
as some overall amplitude x not cause
sine Omega t minus Phi, and you ask
what does this function look like?
But this function is obvious to
all of you. There's oscillating.
Notice that even those
oscillating like of course sign,
it's not in step with the applied force.
The applied forces cost to make a tea.
It's maximum on my Curtis
said zero to Pi four Pi,
etc. This guy's maximum occurs
somewhere later. The first maximum,
my career's been omega.
These equal to defined,
so it's said to be lagging the function.
You can imagine two functions oscillating,
one is behind the other one.
It reaches the maximum slightly later.
So the first property is
in a driven oscillator.
The X will not be in step with the F.
Would you be lagging?
Audit could be leading.
Depends on what fires.
Then what about the
amplitude of installation?
That's the thing that's very interesting.
How big is the oscillation?
It looks like f knife over the m
divided by the absolute value of I.
Let me write the absolute
value of I for you.
Okay,
so the amplitude of oscillation
depends on the frequency.
You got to draw the graph as a
function of frequency. What does the
one over this look like?
Pardon me?
Yes, but a minus B squared
and B minus a square.
That's why I have not been
paying attention. Okay.
Yeah,
so I'm pretty careless on what I put in,
but this is one occasion where I sort
of know it's okay because I'm going to
square this. I don't have to remember
who is Omega naught, who's Omega.
I have be very careful that I
don't square things like here,
but if I'm squaring it doesn't matter.
Okay,
so go back here and plot something divided
by this denominator and ask what does
it at various frequencies.
Yeah.
When Omega is zero, that
goes away. That goes away.
You'll get Omega and odd square and
we'll make an r squared is care with them
and I claim what you will find initially.
Yes,
this'll become f naught over k.
That'll be the value of this whole
amplitudes at zero frequency.
I hope that makes a lot of sense to is
zero frequency means the force is not
even isolating. It's a constant
force. What acts are you going to get?
You're going to get the force
divided by the force constant.
That's the extra which
you will pull this spring.
That's why if you put all the Omegas
and masters back into proper place,
you will find it.
F Not over k.
Then what happens is as Omega
increases this denominator,
one of these guys and denominator,
they're starting to vanish if gamma,
but a very, very tiny number,
but Omega naught equals Omega,
you will be dividing by various small
lumber and the answer will have a huge
rise. Then you can see an Omega
goes to infinity, very large Omega.
You're dividing by Omega Square.
It'll fall off like this.
Now, one of the homework problems is to
find out exactly where it peaks with.
Gamma is very small.
You don't have to do much work to know
it peaks at Omega Equals Omega and arc,
but otherwise he was near that. That's
a phenomenon that's called resonance.
Resonance is the following. You are
playing a force f not constant. May Get t
you go on bedding the frequency
and responds to your force.
The system oscillates the absolute
of Oscillation is the largest.
When the applied frequency is very near,
the natural frequency
predict the limit of very small gamma.
This maximum is very close to a mega knot.
That's called resonance.
If gamma is really tiny,
you can get greives where
it's incredibly peaked.
So that's when system started vibrating
a lot. That's why I'm in here. Car.
It goes over certain bumps.
If they're pediatric,
they are hitting your cotter and
certain frequency and that frequency is
anywhere near the natural frequency of
vibration of your suspension system.
And the car caught begins to resonate.
That is his famous bridge in Tacoma
that was getting hit by these wins.
They were coming at some
frequency and by bad luck,
they coincided with the natural frequency
of the bridge so that as his famous
movies made for high
school and with the bridge,
jostle is more than more than more than
uh, twists and turns and collapses.
That's another example of
resonance. People always say, yeah,
I can resonate with what the person
is saying. What does that mean?
The person is saying
whatever the hell he wants.
Some people think is interesting
and some people think it's boring.
It's the same thing here.
The forces acting at a certain frequency.
If your natural frequency is close to
that, your response is high. If it's low,
you don't care. Same thing. That's
mechanical systems selecting a frequency.
In fact, this is how radios
work. If you have a radio,
if there's only one radio station,
you build an electrical circuits in
which occurred like select to go back and
forth or oscillate at a certain frequency.
Radio stations should send
signals of that frequency.
Your responses will be very high,
but what if there is more than one
radio station which is the fact of life?
What did they do?
What they do is each one sense a
signal at a different frequency.
You'll take your radio and the in signed,
well I forgot you could do you know what
a dialogue is because you are now there
is pushing the some other button. There
is a time when you had to turn the dial.
When you turn a dial,
you're changing the properties,
the electrical circuit and
changing its natural frequency.
You move the natural frequency to the
lines up with the frequency of the radio
station with one particular station.
Then the response from that station is
very high and that's the sound you hear.
Other stations are also present but
you are not near their maximum. Uh,
they were there. We are sitting
somewhere here and somewhere here.
So you want the station frequency
to come under this residence.
Peak is if you've got a bad radio,
it'll pick up sound from any stations
because it's not very refined.
If the peak is broad,
you will get sound from many stations.
You want to build a system which is very
finally sensitive to the frequency and
that requires gamma to be very
small cameras, very, very small.
You can see if gamma is going to zero,
the nominated is one divided by zero.
It's going to be infinite.
So if gamma is very tiny, one
over, very tiniest, very big,
and you can get enormous spikes in
response. And that's what people need.
Okay. The last thing you need to
do this problem set, by the way,
I know this problem sounds very
nasty towards the end. It got tough.
You got email. Uh, I
agree with you that this,
this whole course is somewhat more
difficult than it has always been.
Okay.
I'm aware of that fact and I will bear
this fact in mind when you go into your
final because for some reason,
uh,
I want her to use problems not in
our book for technical reasons.
So I got them from here
and there or made them up.
They generally tend to be more
challenging and more time consuming.
So if you thought this is a tough course,
well,
it's supposed to be a tough course,
but maybe not this hard or
not this time consuming.
So I will remember that in the end of the,
when I make the final exam or look at
your grade, I will have to compare to you,
not simply to your predecessors,
but I love to give you some,
cut you some slack and then compare
to you to previous generations. So,
uh,
this use of complex numbers is something
from which I will not. However,
back down,
it turns out that yes,
you can do all of this without
using complex numbers. Why?
Because in the real world,
everything has got real numbers.
So you can in fact by Rgf triganom metric
identities solve it with science and
course science.
But eventually I'll give you a problem.
But he just cannot do
it in a meaningful way.
The power of complex numbers is they
turn differential equations is into
Algebraic equations.
All you have to do is find the
roots of a quadratic equation.
Whereas what he started out was to find
the solution of a differential equation.
That advantage you will lose if
you stop using complex numbers.
And when you do quantum
mechanics and second term,
a complex numbers are in
the equations of motion.
The analog of f equals I made,
there's an ice sitting there.
So you cannot escape the eye.
It's there.
So I'm saying, uh, depending on
how much exposure you've had,
you have to do more or less work.
But you just got to get
used to complex numbers.
You've got to get used to the
absolute value, the phase angle,
how the metal plate them if you
already to know it that good.
If you don't know it, you have to
do more work than other people,
but I'm not going to
let off on it. Yes, no.
Anything you need to know.
Differential equations is what I've done
for you in the class today. That's it.
That's the only part you know
and with complex numbers,
you turned it into ordinary equations
so you have to go over these steps and
work them out.
That's the part I cannot do for you.
That's something you have to do.
All right.
What is finally missing is that x of t
if I wrote for you or they wrote about
which is [inaudible], I don't want
to write the [inaudible] again.
Is f not or what am I?
Maybe I will write the whole thing.
If not over m divided by absolute value.
I times cosine Omega t minus five it
turns out this is not the full answer to
the question. What happens when I
push a mass? Let's understand why.
Suppose I go to this
mass in spring system,
I grabbed it or t equals
zero and start shaking. Well,
rt equals zero x was zero because
I grabbed her. The t equals zero.
Well at t equals zero if
they go to this solution,
it's not giving me zero each saying
it's ethanol over MRI costs signed Phi.
So what happened to the freedom I had
to assign the velocity and position
arbitrarily. Well, it turns
out that I can still do that.
That's because this solution has got a
part that's actually missing and the part
that's missing is this
complementary solution, eh,
to the minus gamma t over to
cause saying of Omega prime,
t minus finite.
You can always add the
solution to this solution.
Why is that? Because of x obeyed a
certain equation. If I put that in,
I'm saying adding this part will not
change the fact that obeys the equation.
Let's ask ourselves why go
back to the top line there.
F X,
double dark was gamma is dark,
was Omega naught squared x will be
equal to if not over him, make a tea.
If you put this in now, what if you
keep adding? This is the solution.
Will you mess it up?
Imagine adding this to the left hand side,
but I claim on the lefthand side there'll
be no extra terms because this guy
double dark plus gamma at times. This
guy.plus, oh Megan r-squared them.
This guy is zero.
This is the function which you would
say is annihilated by the operations.
On the lefthand side,
it's like saying the following.
If you want to function who's derivative
is equal to the sine x, then I
miss you. I know the function.
There's minus cost sine x and you all
know you can add to that at constant.
Where do you add the constant way doesn't
do screw up everything because the
database to have a constant is zero.
But here this is not a constant and yet
the combination of data reduce appearing
the equation act on
this to give you a zero.
That's why you can add it without
screwing up what you've done so far.
So the way you do these problems is you
first find this function that depends on
the applied force and
you add to this solution.
You get foot free even in the
absence of an applied force. Yes.
Let's call the complimentary function and
this is called the particular solution.
This particular solution depends on
the force and this is the function.
I don't know why it's called compliment.
Maybe it compliments the answer.
It's it's a Freebie.
You don't pay for it with any force
but it's called complimentary,
but you got to add the
two to get the final lands
so you will still have,
this number's a and fine art hanging
around and how do you select them?
You select them if on top of it somebody
tells you that this driven oscillator
had a certain coordinate and
certain velocity at t equals zero,
so you'll evaluate the whole expression
at t equals zero by putting t equals
zero everywhere.
You'll get one equation in wellbeing,
a and fine art and they'll take
the deliberative for the Valencia.
They said that equal to given number.
You got the second equation
involving a and find out,
you will juggle the two equations and
solve for the two numbers and find out,
okay, so that is the whole
story. Okay. That's uh,
that's what I tried to do yesterday,
but this is not the first time it's
happened to me that I tried to go fast in
the end. I lost time because I was not
happy with the way it was explained.
And uh, I usually come back and say
sorry and then do it all over again.
Okay. But that is only so much I can
do. Uh, the rest is up to you guys.
You have to have to do the work
and you have to do more problems.
Okay.
So now we're moving off to
another topic or the other topic.
Uh, somebody was saying that
relief is not very different. Uh,
okay. This is, these are waves,
but I think it's going to be, look,
I think this probably is the hardest
point of what we're doing in this term,
at least mathematically. Everything
else we do, heat, hot water, cold water,
that kind of stuff you've
done in high school.
That's all in near future is going
to be a lot easier. Okay. Waves.
So everyone has a good feeling for waves.
You go to a lake,
you know if you're a
hit man for the mafia,
you're dropping things in with
some weight. They go down.
What's the first thing they do?
Once a body's falling into the water,
it's carving out some body
of water and diving in.
So the water next to it
dives into fill that hole,
but then the water even next to it
drives in to fill the hole left behind by
these guys.
For you it looks like when the ripples
traveling outwards from the center,
so this is the classic example of a way.
If you've got one example,
you can latch onto it.
Every time I say wave,
so what's the wave in this problem?
Yes,
that if I drop plot of the height of the
water versus the place where I dropped
the rock, or maybe I should do it.
Pop view here, this is the top view.
After awhile you got these
ripples emanating from this
point or if you kept your
eye next to the water, you will find
these ups and downs going outwards.
So the wave is some displacement of
a medium. That's what people say.
That's not a perfect definition because
we know electromagnetic waves have no
medium. They travel in vacuum. But I
think for this purpose in this course,
you should imagine a way it was what
happens when you excited medium.
So here's what,
here's the way to think about the way you
all understand the harmonic oscillator
pretty well. White Mass in brings system
in equilibrium will sit there forever.
If you give it a kick,
it'll start vibrating.
I don't this equilibrium position that
you have to keep track only one variable
x,
which is location of the mass.
The wave is an oscillation off a medium.
That means at every point in space that
is something that's ready to oscillate.
So it's not a system with one degree
of freedom system, infinite numbers,
big does of freedom because the height
of the water at each point is an
independent variable.
It can jump up and down with time
and that's what is oscillating.
So if you don't do anything but the water,
it'll stay at that height.
But if you fiddled with it,
you dropped something,
you hit it with something
and start vibrating.
But except this is the vibration not of
one variable but if available in space
and time x was a function of time
and the name we use for the wave,
if something is oscillating such as the
water measurement from some point x,
I'm going to use the symbol sigh of x,
the Dennard,
the height of the water from its normal
position at the point x at time t
so x is not a dynamical variable here.
X labels the point size,
the dynamical available size.
The thing jumping up in though,
okay no,
that are two kinds of waves.
That's the longitudinal
wave and the transfers wave
and we define them as follows.
The way of travels out with some velocity,
so I'm going to use the symbol
v for the velocity of the wave.
That's something for which all of you
have good intuitive understanding,
so no need to mess it up right now.
You go to the lake, you drop a rock,
you see when the waves get to the shore,
you take the distance divided by time.
That's the velocity in sound.
You know you light up a firecracker
after a while you hear it.
You can see how long it took and how far
you are and you can find the velocity.
That's the velocity of sound in air.
No, these velocities are all variable.
I liked the velocity of light.
That doesn't seem to depend on anything.
All of that. The cities, depending on
various conditions, double last year,
sound depends on the
temperature for example,
or do you can take the following thing.
You can take an iron rod,
which you know is made up a lot of atoms
and you'll take a hammer and you hit it.
Here you stand.
You basically,
you compress these atoms and they compress
the atoms next to them and the shock
waves travels through this ride that's
also called sound that travels at the
speed, which is much faster
than the speed of sound in air,
but it is technically also called sound.
If you were to create your
living inside the iron bar,
you will think of it as sound. Here's
another way you can hear it. Um,
for example is the standard example.
Here's the railway track and that is
some kind of a mountain here and you,
you're over here and the
train is coming here.
It turns out if the train
lets out a sound, you will,
the sound will travel around
the band and you will hear it.
But actually the pounding
of the train on the tracks,
we'll set up shock waves in the track
that you can hear by putting your ear to
the track and you will hear the train
before you hit it by depending on the
sound coming through the air.
Because the waves going through
the solid travel much faster.
Okay. So I would recommend that
if you're going to do this,
you do the somewhere here because you
want to have enough time to move if you do
it here. Okay? So most of the
things, please don't do this at home.
This would be done by a trained person,
but I certainly did it as a kid.
Listen for trains before they come around
the bend. And you can actually hit it.
The track audit in water,
that explorations in water,
you can hear them fast,
that if you're under the water,
then if you're outside the water,
because the waves travel faster in water,
then in a thunder and lightning is the
most famous example of something happens
in the sky. This light gets to you
first and the sound gets to you.
You're traveling at different velocities.
Okay,
so now let's talk about longitudinal
transfers. Waves. When I talked to you,
I think you sort of know what happens.
The ad in this room is have some pressure
and that pressure is constant
and the pressure is pushing you.
The Ed room from the outside
is going through your uh,
istation count pushing the drum from the
insight and the two pressures balance
and you don't feel
anything. If I talk, uh,
the vocal cards move back and forth and
the increase in decrease the pressure as
I talk. If I push out, increased
the pressure. If I go backwards,
I decompress the editor.
Reduce the pressure though.
Shock waves propagate dod year,
they hit your ear drum.
But the ear drum is getting the
pressure different from the outside,
but the inside pressure is fixed.
So what happens is when I decompressed,
the ear drum comes out and it goes in,
it goes back and forth
and the ear drum moves.
Then behind the Ed round might be a little
bones and then the bones go and that
is some tube and there's not the
doctors take over from this point.
So some loose Harris
shaking in this fluid,
then it picks up some nervous
things and goes to your brain.
Then you figured out, you know, you at
least know what the person's saying.
You know how she's, your wife is
talking to this particular fashion.
But you can at least
understand and translate.
So that's a long chain of transducers of
energy from sound to the stuff in your
year into your brain.
I draw the line of the hydro.
I don't want to go on the other side of
the head. Drunk cause a very shaky turf,
but the part,
this part I know very well,
it's a sound wave and it's a longitudinal
wave for the following reason.
If you look at the pressure waves,
the molecules of air,
they're going back and forth following
my hands and the signal from me to you.
It's also going from me to you. So the
motion is in line with the velocity.
The motion of the medium isn't the same
direction as the motion of the wave.
A transverse wave is what you find
in water. If you are on a string,
take a string clamped or that. Then they
do give it a little flick like that.
This bump after a while it will end up
here is the rope is moving transfers,
but the velocity of the
signal is to the right.
So do not confuse the motion of the
medium with the motion of the signal.
Okay. The rope at any given point is
either at rest or going up and down,
but the signal is going
from left to right.
So the medium doesn't have to actually
move in the direction of the wave.
For example,
if a bunch of people line up and each
one tells the person next to the next
person some secret and the secret is
eventually transmitted all the way at the
end.
What does travel is a secret.
The actual person in the first place
has not gone over physically to the end.
So what happens is you are sitting there
not doing anything and suddenly you
hear something,
you pass it on to the next person,
then you've gone back to doing nothing.
Then the signal travels.
That's what'll happen in the rope here.
This section of the rope is not doing
anything. When this pulse hits that,
it'll jump up and down for a while.
Then it'll quiet down and somebody to
the right. We'll start moving. Okay,
so they had the examples of
longitudinal and transfers waves.
So we have have the notion of velocity.
No.
I want to consider one concrete example
of a wave so you people have a good
feeling of how to study waves in physics.
Yeah,
so that are many, many waves, water waves,
electromagnetic waves, elastic waves.
I'm going to do one,
I think to do one thing in some depth.
We'll give you a feeling for hobby analyze
waves. That's going to be waves on a,
so you have to imagine that I have a
string as being clamped the two n's and
somebody plucks the string say
into that shape and Lex go,
we know the string is going
to vibrate back and forth.
Let's measure the cord in it.
X,
which is the point on the string and
PSI is the displacement of the string.
At that point you guys got
that. This is really the x axis.
This is not my string.
That is my string.
Each point is labeled by an x value that
it would have the string relax to the
normal position.
We are asking what is the displacement
of the string at the point x at time t
society is so new,
dynamical Beatty,
namely the variable for which we like
to write the equations governing his
motion. And we want to ask
how does cyber 80 but time,
what will it do if I started out,
what will it do?
You understand the parallel
to the mass in spring system,
the mass in spring system,
you've got a mass and you've got a spring,
you pull the mass out
to some new location,
you let it go and you
want to know what it does.
The answer was Casa mega t no.
At every point x,
I have some string and I displaced all
those degrees of freedom and I let them
go and they're going to do something and
I want to know how they are all very,
so previously we had only one coordinator,
which they call x with varied with time.
Now at every point x,
I have a coordinate side that varies
with time and while job is to find the
equation satisfied by sy.
Okay,
so let us take a string and the
string has to be under some tension.
That means you hang some weights on the
end or you tighten it with some screws.
That's attention, tension so that the
string is willing to dying to break apart.
If you cut it to a t. T is the tension on
the string without detention? Uh, none,
none of this will work.
So he had a string.
Okay.
And I'm going to analyze
the fate of assignee.
Tiny segment of length.
DX.
An essential it did here is called
[inaudible], which is the mass,
but unit length. That means you put
the string on a weighing machine,
you find a mass and you divided
by the length. For example,
if you've got a 10 meters ring and
it weighs a one 10th of a kilogram,
then the masculine it link is one
over thousand kilograms per meter.
And t is the tension.
The textbook may use F for tension
because t is the time period also.
So it depends on what
symbol they use in the book.
I'm not completely sure I'm going to
call it t because it's been called tea in
the past.
Now I pulled this and I want to
know what the whole string we'll do.
Who is going to tell me now, man, I mean,
what authority will decide
the behavior of the strings?
What do we have to appeal to?
Yes.
Pardon me.
Very good.
So he said,
find the force that will return
it to the original position.
And what was the issue that you mentioned?
Pardon me.
Right. But, uh, we are going to apply.
Yes. Any other answers before they go?
Yes.
Modeled the emotion of the story by
saying that by pretending that just using
some point in and being like, this is, the
motion is just the same as if we had a,
uh, a us, us, us,
mass on sprint and it's
oscillating back and forth.
Yeah. It will look like that.
That is correct. But you all,
I want you to understand this,
that are no new laws that I'm going
to invoke. I'm not going to say, well,
we just started master's in spring.
Today's time to study strings and I'm
going to tell you a new law of motion.
There's only one law of
motion that is f equals m. A.
The whole purpose of my exercise now
is to show you that really does control
that way.
It's Super Law.
Everything mechanical follows from that
law and I want to show you ethicals mas
all I have and I got to use it properly.
That's going to tell me
what the string will do.
So what I do is the string is of course
a long and extended and complicated
object.
I isolate a portion of it of lengthy x
and I'm going to apply ethical CMA to
that guy.
All I need to know is the f the total
force on it and I'm going to eat better to
mass times acceleration.
Okay.
Now this force on this little segment
is the tension pulling this way,
the same tension pulling that way,
the tension on the string,
it doesn't change from point to point,
but the angle at which it is pulling
is not necessarily the same. Here,
there is some angle theta plus Delta
data and here there is an angle data.
This force is at an angle to
say Tara below the horizontal,
this pulling about a plus delta data,
so the string is curving.
Therefore the the tangent to the string
at this end and that end are not quite
the same and that's the key because
if they were exactly the same,
the same tension on the two ends.
If you take any object like this
and apply exactly the same force,
they will cancel because the opposite
forces andF is zero and may will be zero
and this thing won't move.
The reason that moves is because even
though the magnitude of the force is the
same, the angle at which
is acting is not the same.
So I'm going to find out the component
of the force here and take the difference
from there.
It's the force here we'd be tee
times sine theta plus Delta Theta.
Theta is the angle with the horizontal
and the force of the other side
will be tee times. Sine Theta.
Theta is the angle made by the string
from the horizontal and that angle is some
changing over this tiny lane.
Yeah.
Next approximation. That's
the force that's going to
be mass times acceleration.
Mass up this little segment.
Is the mass per unit length times
the length of the segment? No.
What is the acceleration in
the language of Calculus?
What does the acceleration here?
Pardon me.
Ah, he said deep two x over Dt Square,
but the d by Dt squared is right.
It's not d two of x off side
because you've got to understand,
I think, look, this was not fair trick,
but you have to be aware that what is
oscillating up and down is the coordinate.
I X is not a real dynamical court
in excess. A label on the string.
What? Jumping up and down the PSI, so
the acceleration, the second bit of it,
and I write partial derivative
because psych can vary with X.
Audit can vary with time and I want
to take the second time did have it.
Yeah.
Now come to the lefthand side and you
assume the angles involved. Very small.
The angles involved are very small. I
remind you guys at the following identity,
sine theta begins
sustained up plus.dot dot.
You remember the CTSA award for you?
Of course signed data is one minus data
squared over two and we have decided
that we are going to treat data
is so small that data square,
we're not interested and 10 data which
is [inaudible] is now state over one.
We just stayed up.
So small angle approximation is scientists
though approximately equal potato
corn sainted approximately equal to one
10 data maybe approximately the place
might data.
So first nice break.
We don't have to work with sign with
just one t of data plus Delta Theta minus
that which is dealt at data.
Yeah,
Delta Theta is a change in the angle from
the left end of the string bit to the
right end of the string
bean. No, I got a d x here,
so what I'm going to do is divide
by a dx and multiplied by the x.
We are almost there in
did I in the equation?
I look, I've been calling a dx and Delta
x so pardon that? Just call it, uh,
just dx.
You the x,
the two PSI over Dt Square.
Now what does the data,
I'm going to say data is the same as Stan
data in the small angle approximation.
Tamp data is these side the x,
you know from the calculus,
if you're more horizontally by DX,
a new move vertically by the PSI.
These ideas is the Tan of the angle.
That's one of the first things
you learned in calculus.
So this is really de by Dx of
these IDX that becomes deep.
Two PSI over dx squared equals the mew,
the two psi over Dt Square.
Now some of you may find
the derivation heart,
then forget about the details.
You're not responsible for that.
But some of you may say,
look,
I don't ever want you to tell me something
which you cannot prove unless it's an
axiom or the law of nature.
But this is not a new law of nature.
So I have to tell you where I got this.
I got this by applying f equals
m a tiny portion of the string.
And you can ask yourself, when you pull
a string up, why does it come down?
It comes down because there's a tension
on the string and the tension here and
the tension here have vertical
components that don't quite match.
You see the string is
flattening out like this.
The vertical downward component of
this is bigger than the vertical upward
component of this force. If it resolve
it, the vertical, horizontal part,
the downward part is bigger than the
upward part in this picture that there's a
net force bringing you down.
But I'm not bringing you down is because
the deliberative here and here are not
the same because the
derivative is the slope.
So the whole thing depends on the rate
of change of the rate of change and
that's why you get this. But the mass
of the tiny segment also depends on dx.
So dx cancels in the end,
you drop it and you get this equation.
So what I want you to
think of is dictated.
DX is really d by the x of these IDX.
And but I should actually use partial
data with this because I depends on x,
empty. So if you a little careful with
that, you get d two Psi over DP Square.
So now I'm going to write
down the final wave equation.
From this point on, you have to get
engaged in the problem because you,
even though you may or may
not follow the derivation,
you should know what is
called the wave equation.
This is the way we
equation d two PSI over.
DX squared is equal to
one over v Square,
d two Psi or d p square,
but v square is equal to
t over a meal or to be the
square root of p over me.
I just invented a symbol [inaudible].
This is very important.
What do you have to know is that Cy,
the displacement of the string at the
point caught labeled x horizontally from
the left hand at the time t varies
with time according to this equation.
This is a very famous equation and it
turns out you take any elastic medium and
you are disturbed a little
bit from equilibrium,
always seems to be patients of this type.
So our job from now till sometime is
to analyze the equation and see what it
means, what are the consequences
of this wave equation.
And even though I call it d,
it has UNICEF velocity,
I have no right to argue that it
really is the velocity of the wave.
We'll have to find out
it got dimensions of velocity.
You can check by putting the units yet.
Okay,
but now let me write down a
solution to this equation.
Then we will understand
what can happen.
So this is like saying I got some
equation, second database to Webex.
Yeah
is equal to some number claims,
sex and we set the answer this constantly
got tea and sine Omega t but nobody
got secondary to the perspective space.
Second did it with respect to time
and I know that this guy is going to
oscillate up and down,
but he's going to oscillate.
If you imagine a string,
if you take a string out of waterway,
which is traveling back and forth,
the triplets at traveling,
if you took a snapshot of
the way at a given time,
it'll be going up and down in space.
Artifice stored at one point in the
water and have the wave go past you.
The water will go up and down
in time at a given space.
I understand it. The waves coming towards
the shore. Do you stand in one place?
You don't. You don't have to move the
way we'll go past you and Brad you are.
The water will go up
and down with time art.
If you took a picture
of it at one instant,
the way it will go up and
down in space at a given time.
So waves oscillate in space and time
and you have to guess the answer.
Now if I had more time I can tell you
guys how did they use the answer is not
very hard but I just don't have that
kind of time so I'm going to just write
down his solution and in fact there are
many, many solution to the equation.
It's very general.
So I'm going read a particular solution.
The solution I'm going to write down,
it looks like this is some
number which to the amplitude
and it looks like cause sign
some number called k
times x minus Omega T.
Unfortunately this case
not a force constant.
It is some new symbol and Omega is another
symbol who's meeting we will deduce
shortly.
Yeah,
at least you can see that I just
cannot right away of like x minus t or
something cause of course should have
an argument with this nor dimensions,
so if I have an ex I should multiply
multiplied by some number that's got units
of inverse x and if I have a time I should
multiply by something that looks like
a frequency from dimensional analysis.
I look for a solution of this foreign
to these equations. Once again,
whether you saw this is by the way is
called a partial differential equation
because it involves partial [inaudible].
All I'm going to be doing,
I'm going to be content with this showing
you that this solution when I stick it
into this equation actually works.
Let us first verify that it works.
Then it will come next Monday and analyze
in detail what does this really do?
We'll come to that in a moment.
Let's verify that it works.
So let's take this IDX.
What happens when you take these IDX?
When you take a partial, a little bit
of an x, it says, forget about time,
treat x as the only variable.
Then you will get minus a sign k,
x minus Omega t times or did I bet
too of what's inside the argument,
which happens to be key
knife.
You differentiate the second
time the two side, the x square,
you do the whole thing again and
then you'll get minus a k square
sign.
K X minus Omega t
I'm sorry. Yes, thank you. No,
you should take d two psy d t square.
You would get minus Omega
squared, a uh, course sign,
k x minus Omega t.
You could take one over v squared
times that you would get this.
Okay.
What does the wave equation say?
It says the secondary way to have an
x should be one of [inaudible] to the
second derivative in time and
for my solution, that's a second.
Did a bit of an ex that a second time.
I want them to match.
Well, they're almost there. A
matches. The cost matches the cost,
but Omega and care not independent numbers
or may go over to v should be equal
to k.
In other words,
this wave equation for waves on a string,
we'll have solutions that look like this
where it can be any number you like k
and Omega between the two of them.
That is one degree of freedom.
You can pick k at will and pick Omega so
that Omega equals kv pick Omega freely
and choose case or that case we'll make
a over B but that is a relation between
the two of them,
which you can write in any number of ways.
So let us put that knowledge
back into the solution.
Let us say omega is in fact kv so that
the write that explicitly in terms of the
CAE,
which is completely free to sign now
looks like a cause k times x minus I hear
is about you guys gotta do a little mental
Algebra here. If I pull the key out,
can you see the tea? Will be multiplied
by Omega over k but Omega over case v.
Okay,
so this is my solution.
It costs k x minus V t
and that is a very
pretty result and I just,
I will conclude by telling
you what that is telling.
It stays the CFX t which depends on x
and depends on ti depends on x and t
through this combination.
X minus bt. Other words,
if I explained this a bt has a certain
value science, a certain value.
If I change x and if I change
t keeping x minus vd constant,
the function doesn't change,
right? Because it's functionally
of this combination.
I will argue that that really means it's
the way of this traveling at a velocity
v.
Let me show you why.
Let's take a function e
to the minus x squared.
You must've seen this function in
statistics. It looks like this.
It likes to have x equals zero
take the function that exited,
he placed by x minus v.
T
where does this function?
Habits maximum you'd has the maximum when
this guy on top vanishes that just say
when x equal to Vt.
So if you took the function,
either the x minus V t square,
the minus sign [inaudible] be here
at at that time it'll be here,
but at every instant the bump,
we'll be moving to the right.
You can see with the Velocity v
because the peak is at a location VT,
so in a way of the whole profile,
what was it,
the velocity and therefore this symbol
we use here is in fact the velocity of
the wave.
Well,
maybe I'll give you one extreme example.
Arctic will the zero.
It just looks like co was k x and we
all know what costs and Kx looks like.
It's got a maximum at x equal to zero.
If you wait a little
longer had is that bad?
Is this maximum little later
increased x a little bit.
If you increased time a little bit,
you've got increased x a little bit so
that these two still cancel each other.
Originally,
experts at zero and t was a zero.
You're at a maximum little
later after some time built a t.
If you go to the point delta x
so that these two numbers cancel,
you're still writing the maximum,
but that means the delta
x over Delta t is v.
That means if you moved to the right
after same delta t you would ride the,
that means the crest is moving at the
Velocity v so I think to summarize what
I've shown you so far is that
when you take a string and you,
I have attention on it,
you pull it and let it go.
It vibrates according to this
equation that the first statement,
this is a solution.
I'm not telling you it's the most gentle
one or the only one that anything I
want to start at least have one concrete
solution and I'm not told you yet how
to visualize the function or I have
told you whatever the function is,
it is drifting to the right at a speed
that we call me because any function of x
minus VT has a property that if
it did something at x equals zero.
It does the same thing
that x equals the Vt.
That means the whole shape is
bodily transported to the right.
So this really signifies a
wave traveling to the right.
If you wanted a way of traveling to the
left, we should put a plus sign here.
Then we'll go backwards.